Ah! Hi, Miss.
What's the matter?
Something. Something touched me.
It was wet.
Oh.
Were you not given the audio guide?
No, no, no, no.
I got here late.
Here.
Thank you. Yeah.
Hi, I'm Jacob Ticketmaster.
Let me be the first to thank you for
sitting in the least desirable seats of
the whole theater. The back corner
because of what the Swiss call the
theater bobbers, what the Germans call
schwein on penis and what we in America
call Ticketmaster babies.
My family proudly genetically
engineered these night freaks in the
1920s in a quest to create an usher
that could live within the theater
walls and subsist solely off of wood
and twizzler pull and peels.
Jesus. Unfortunately, shit went so, so
wrong. And now we are stuck with these
unspeakable horrors who pop out of the
theater walls and try to give you a
kiss. The kiss of the pig is what the
Germans call it Eyeless and dickless.
The theater Baba is a nightmare to
behold. Judy Garland has a wonderful
quote about them. To call them a beaver
is an insult to beavers.
Genetically, they're actually closer to
a spider or a mosquito.
Judy Garland had a knack for zoology.
I'm holding one now that, as you can
see, is in shock from a Twizzler binge.
This is a ghastly sight to come popping
out in the middle of a theatrical
performance. So we're going to need you
to confirm your willingness to perform
the role of Baba Inspector to an usher.
Vocally, the usher will then give you a
spray to defend yourself should spines
come popping out looking for a smooch.
They won't rest till they get their
kisses. So it is up to you to protect
yourself from the penisless pigs.
Thank you for coming tonight and please
enjoy tonight's performance of Stomp.
Avenue Q or Chris Fleming.
May I have a verbal confirmation of your
consent to be a bauver inspector
tonight?
Yeah. You know, it's kind of a tall
order, but okay.
Use as much as you want, but want as
much as you use.
My queen. I have failed you.
How many patrons did you smooch?
One. Barely.
Silence.
If we don't get to first with at least
five patrons by nightfall, then he will
be banished to a dinner theater in
Phoenix where they do murder mystery
comedies. Please, my queen.
I'll give you my family's.
Rations for this whole week.
Don't make me squirt peasant.
I could floss with those pulling peels.
Look at mine.
Thick as rope. I could dock a boat with
my own peels.
Now go plant one on five patrons before
the night is up or you will be flying
spirit to Maricopa county tonight.
Hahahahaha. Hahahahahahaha.
Hi daddy. How was work?
Will you be home early tonight?
No girls, not tonight.
Daddy's got some smooching to do.
Oh.